hi i'm alicia and today i'm super
excited to talk about apogee x
which is the latest release of google
cloud's apigee api management platform
businesses have been executing on
digital transformation strategies for
many years
however the covid19 outbreak drastically
changed consumer behavior and work
environments
forcing businesses to quickly adapt and
accelerate their efforts to meet new
digital demands
such as delivering a connected seamless
digital experience
automating as many manual processes as
possible
operating anywhere with distributed
remote workforce
and unlocking new revenue streams
in order to meet these new demands
organizations should really think beyond
digital transformation
and strive to achieve digital excellence
apis are key to driving digital
excellence they enable companies to
deliver seamless experiences
modernize applications abstract the
complexity of legacy systems
and unlock new revenue streams as
enterprises rapidly scale and globalize
their digital transformation programs
their underlying api programs follow
correspondingly
therefore businesses need a very
comprehensive and powerful api
management platform
to support the new digital needs
apigee x helps businesses accelerate and
globalize their api programs to achieve
digital excellence it allows them to
deliver secure
high-performing reliable apis across the
globe with an integrated approach to
artificial intelligence
web application firewall identity
management
content delivery network and other
advanced cloud capabilities
let's take a closer look apogee x comes
with out of the box integration with
cloud cdn
which leverages the same network that
google uses to host its apps
used by billions of users this allows
you to deploy
and deliver high-performing apis across
24 regions
and 73 zones with caching across 93
points of presence
it provides multiple layers of security
for your apis
eliminating the need to integrate with
third-party solutions for web
application firewall and identity
management needs
apigee x is powered by google cloud's
industry leading ai
you can now apply machine intelligence
to automate trivial tasks related to api
operations and api security
so that you can really focus on business
critical activities
last but not least it provides the
flexibility to store data in the region
of your choice
gives you more control on encrypted data
and ensures that your business adheres
to all regulatory and compliance
requirements
let's see a quick demo of how this works
apogee x provides self-service
capabilities to create your own orgs and
environments to create an org simply
click
edit select the analytics hosting region
and enter the encryption key
after configuring the network and
runtime parameters
you can now create an environment by
providing the required details
for the purpose of this demo i created a
hello world proxy
added a few developers and registered to
front end app
if i try to access the proxy without a
key it fails
to further protect this proxy with cloud
armor you can create a new rule
or apply an existing rule to the api
proxy
when i try to access the same proxy
again without a key
you'll see a change in the error message
generated by cloud armor
now let's see how to apply cloud cdn
capabilities to your apis for enhanced
caching and performance
i created a very simple cdn policy and
applied it to the load balancer
in addition i added cache control so
that cloud cdn knows to cache the
responses
when i access the proxy from us west the
call is executed in about 10
milliseconds
if i take the same call and execute it
from a vm located in europe west
the response time for the first attempt
is about 215 milliseconds
[Music]
however because of the enhanced caching
the response time for the second attempt
goes down to 16 milliseconds
this was just a quick preview of apigee
x
in summary apigee x allows you to
deliver secure
high-performing reliable apis across the
globe with an integrated approach to
artificial intelligence
web application firewall identity
management
content delivery network and other
advanced cloud capabilities
now it's your turn to try it out and get
started by following the links in the
description below